this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your
story live from the headquarters of
ramsey solutions it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice george campbell ramsey
personality is my co-host today he's
also the host of the entree leadership
podcast and the podcast that has
absolutely exploded in listenership
called the fine print you can find all
of those with ramsey networks be sure
and check them out we're here today to
talk to you about your relationships
your mental health your boundaries your
money your job your career whatever it
is in your life you want to talk about
it's a free call some say the advice is
worth exactly what you pay for it the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
jennifer starts this hour off in new
york city hi jennifer welcome to the
ramsey show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
sure what's up
i have a question um
ron baby step number two and to increase
our income i decided to write a book
now i've recently finished it but i
don't know where to go from here there's
so many
master classes and websites and
all of these things out there and you
don't know if it's a scam or not to
platform it i don't know where to put it
um
okay good question what's your book
about
um how to begin your gluten-free
lifestyle when you get diagnosed with
celiac disease wow okay
wow
well um
what we did uh the very first book i did
was called financial peace and um
i i you know it was very analog world in
those days there was no internet and so
it was all about just
guerrilla marketing we called it just
hand-to-hand combat
uh and just how can we get the book out
there today you've got some digital
tools available to you that make it much
much easier than the way i did carrying
the books around in the trunk of my car
and
so
what i would tell you to do first is
probably just jump on the amazon
platform um you can take your manuscript
download it put a cover on it um and
just sell it as an e i sell it as a
demand and they'll print them sell them
on demand they've got a whole publishing
system there
and get started with that it's not very
economical
and so you don't make a ton of money
on your first few thousand books but you
can get the book started get it moving
make some money on it before you spend a
bunch of money to market it okay okay um
the second thing i would do is i
investigate on-demand printing other
than amazon
um and then i would be looking for
websites like the celiac anything having
to do with celiac right
and try to try to write articles uh with
some keywords in it that bring up celiac
so people that are searching celiac will
find that and it can link to your book
you can even you can link them to your
amazon that'd be okay to do too but
somehow uh
let that world that's out there know
that you've got some ideas and opinions
about it
george you've done a lot of george
you've done a lot of online marketing
yeah matter of fact that's what you used
to do before your personality free so
this is a great cross hair are you
really yeah and well my wife is is
celiac and so i i didn't adopt it
because of that
but why did i answer this question
nobody knows well the principles still
stand but i just had some ideas for on
top of everything you said which is
great advice uh first of all as a side
hustle you may want a more reliable
source of income so you may want to go
do something that can produce money
today because the book may not take off
like wildfire this could be a five-year
journey to get this kind of business off
the ground but something else you could
do is nutrition coaching and then the
book can be a part of that as an add-on
so that may be something you can do
today we sit down with people who are
recently done
but i'm just a
person suffering from celiac my daughter
has celiac and i just remember how
overwhelming it was
not to know where to start oh absolutely
i think it's a great resource i'm not an
expert but i just wanted to help the
people there's a lot of like facebook
groups that you can jump into and start
offering some of your resources and say
hey i was just diagnosed with this i
wrote a guide that i i hope helps others
that are experiencing this and if you
search on the internet there's tons of
forums people that are wondering about
this recently diagnosed and they want to
know how to navigate this so you need to
be proactive and going to find those
people right now to get this thing off
the ground and the good news is you can
do that any time of the day
like after the after the kids are asleep
you know i mean you you can hustle while
others sleep
in uh working these chat rooms working
these forums working these facebook
groups and if you've set the book up as
an on-demand uh amazon product you can
just drop your amazon link in there and
go if you want it here it is and
but i i would suggest uh
not overtly selling but instead kind of
give your opinion give some suggestions
give some help
empathize show them how you felt in in
your response say on a facebook group if
you go in there and just start selling
stuff a lot of them will boot you out
but if you go i did all this and i wrote
this if you want it it's okay but um you
don't have to go in there and be the
bookseller of the world
but george is right i think some other
streams of income are going to be really
important uh this is a missional thing
for you matters deeply to you but here's
the actual numbers okay
of all the books published in the united
states
90 and by publishers professional
publishers that are supposed to know
what they're doing 90 of them never sell
over 8 000 copies
okay so a book that sells a hundred
thousand copies or more is a is a
unicorn there's not many of them
now we specialize in unicorn production
here at ramsey solutions
our books generally sell several hundred
thousand copies uh baby steps
millionaires for instance is about to
hit 300 000 it came out in january so
but we've been doing this bestseller
stuff a long time and we have an
unusually large marketing platform that
allow us to create those situations but
just to tell you just putting a book out
in the wild and never having done it
before checks to come in and not really
having a platform the chances of it
and your your subject honestly is very
nuanced uh to the point that george
deals within his home every day and i
didn't even know it and i know george
pretty well so it just i mean you're
going to have a limited audience
obviously and so it's not it's not a
broad market
uh
subject yeah it's a nuanced subject it's
not for anyone who wants to lead a
healthy lifestyle it's a very specific
thing but dave your story of putting
your book in a video store back in the
day is inspiring and that's the kind of
proactive mindset i want jennifer to
have where she goes i'm going to go to a
local business a nutrition coach and say
hey can i put my my book out front okay
i'll split the call you know whatever
that is get creative and start trying
different things out have some fun with
it but i think my point is back to yours
and that is
let's not count on this to be real side
hustle income it might be just more
missional it may not get you out of debt
faster if it makes some money that'll be
great too i'm glad for that but i think
you'll make a whole lot more money doing
a more traditional side hustle uh as
while you're working on your book do
both you know but but if you're saying
this is going to get me out of debt no
it's not
low probability of that uh the length of
time it took me to sell my first 1000
books
uh was absolutely amazing
and again i was doing in an analog world
i didn't have the benefit of on-demand
publishing i didn't there was no such
thing as chat rooms or forums or just an
instagram account there were chat rooms
it was just called the lunchroom at the
uh middle school that was called a chat
room but there was no there was no
internet so
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
well george we're really excited ramsey
solutions is hitting the road
you guys out there already know that our
building wealth event is coming to las
vegas and orlando in may and
we're pumped to add a few more cities
for the fall more to come but already
we're adding this week sacramento in the
fall minneapolis in the fall and san
antonio in the fall tickets are on sale
now for the building wealth live event
we're going to tackle the latest get to
get rich quick trends dive deep into
investing saving planning for retirement
might sound like a lot of complicated
stuff but the truth is it's way easier
than you think me and rachel cruz and
george campbell will do this along with
uh george along with dr john delony and
ken coleman will be there all of us will
be signing books taking photos hanging
out with you guys in each of these
cities so tickets are on sale now for
las vegas may 5 orlando may 19. sac
almost sold out both of those sacramento
just on sale november 1st minnesota
november 10th that's minneapolis and san
antonio november
15th tickets are only 25 you can get a
four pack for 60
which is less than the cost of a pizza
these days after inflation so bring your
friends because it's going to be amazing
set up a get a couple two couples of you
or something or four buddies or four
gals or something and come on we'd love
to have you uh 60 bucks is a deal for a
four pack go to ramseysolutions.com
events to learn even more and we'll see
you there that's ramsey solutions.com
events george i'm so ready to be back on
the road oh i can't wait and the fact
that we're kicking off a building wealth
event in vegas and telling people how to
get rich slow the irony is rich
i'm excited about this
it's a super fun event you know it
didn't even occur to me i just we found
a good venue and it was a good city and
i never even thought about the irony i
just did we just did it and there you go
but leave it to you to figure that out
you can spend 25 bucks on this event or
you can hit the slots
and you'll be done well our event will
last several hours the slots will ask
about last about a minute and a half
that's true and you'll be done more bang
for your buck coming in and you're done
well join us it's gonna be a great time
we did this event uh locally here and
now we're taking on the road and i can't
wait each of these venues we didn't do
super large venues they're only about 2
000 folks and so they're going to sell
out early
every one of them uh so i mean we just
put it on sale yesterday and several
hundred tickets out the door on each of
those folks people are tagging me they
said sacramento meet and greet sold out
i wanted to get my ticket so jump on it
it really will disappear it's already
gone okay wow there you go not not the
whole thing but this is the meet and
greet yeah okay if you want photos and
book signing and all that good stuff so
cool yeah the whole gang's coming or
most of the gang anyway
and as far as the ramsey personalities
team and we're really really excited we
we like being with people and it turns
out people need to be around people it's
healthy it's a good thing and god said
it is not good that men be alone there
you go so um human beings need to hang
out with other human beings that's how
this is you're just sick of staring into
cameras for live streams you want to be
on a real stage with real people not
staring into a black hole of the abyss
yeah i was sick of live streams about
the first minute and a half i did one so
um i like human beings in the audience
and having an interaction it's it's just
a whole lot it's a different energy a
lot more fun for us a lot more fun for
you
so uh come on out guys joseph is in
seattle hi joseph welcome to the ramsey
show
hey dave uh appreciate you taking my
call today sure what's up um
well i'm finishing off the baby steps
and super excited to start building
wealth um i would love to get into real
estate investing but i have no
experience with real estate investing
i'm wondering if it would make more
sense for me at this point um rather
than directly investing in real estate
to invest in some high dividend reits
that would be paying like 10 11
dividends uh or to you know get deeper
into actual physical real estate
either one's fine i mean
the reits in the old days underperformed
growth stock mutual funds these days
there's plenty of reits that are
performing as well
and like you said 10 11 12 is not
unusual on a reit especially in a market
where real estate's doing what it's
doing
ri for those of you don't know is a real
estate investment trust it's basically a
mutual fund for real estate is how it
functions
and so um
and that way you can put in you know a
few thousand dollars versus uh needing
fifty or a hundred thousand dollars to
be in the real estate world uh so what
do you make
uh i make about 550 a year
whoa
what do you do for a living
i'm an economist good for you good for
you it's working out for you
i'm proud of it well done great love oh
thank you appreciate it love what i do
your debt-free house and everything then
you said you finished the baby steps
yeah so well we're just uh actually just
we got got a pretty good change in my
comment structure this last year and so
this puts us in uh in a range of
finishing the baby steps in the next
couple of years so okay and i think
thinking forward to the next steps
gotcha gotcha okay well when you when
you're out of debt with your home and
you make 550 a year you ought to be able
to save up a couple hundred thousand
pretty quick
yeah yeah i mean
it works but again i mean i i don't have
the experience with uh with taking care
of real estate dealing with the property
management and i know there's a lot of
understanding of markets that have to go
into finding the right locations and
there's you know a lot of
a lot of learning to go into there and
as much as i i love learning i also want
to you know get that real estate
investment going
yeah
well i think what you're identifying is
some holes in your knowledge some
knowledge gap
and you fill in that knowledge gap
before you start dropping a couple
hundred grand on something so
probably would start with some reits and
then just go okay i'm gonna go learn
three neighborhoods this year or three
areas of of seattle uh if you're
thinking about residential i'm gonna
start talking to and interviewing
property managers learn how this works
uh i'm gonna learn how talk to some
people that have property and start
looking at best practices on landlording
and uh start you know reading some books
on the subject and you know start
filling in your knowledge gap if you
really want to put money in it you need
to know more uh and that will lower the
fear that that we hear in your voice
right now
yeah and when it comes to this you know
obviously we want you to have a paid for
house which you should be able to do
fairly quickly and then i want you to be
paying cash and i know that's going to
move a lot slower than the courses you
hear about out there from really real
estate gurus but dave after going
bankrupt you started building back your
real estate portfolio in cash and the
amount of financial peace that gives you
and return that gives you is absolutely
incredible well my rates of return are
ridiculous
i don't have any debt
and so the real estate makes money like
crazy when you buy it that way
um it's a little slower to get started
it's not get rich quick but the guys
that are doing the nothing down real
estate
and that are screaming and yelling about
you know debt is you know people who
tell people cash is horrible don't be in
the cash business they they're screwing
they're having a fit out there flopping
around on the floor foaming at the mouth
and carrying on the guys are doing that
stuff
um
basically if you follow that
i defy you to find someone that 10 years
later is not broke
when you do nothing down real estate i
was in a nothing down real estate club
100 of people that were in that club are
no longer in real estate or
they paid it off
and got out of the nothing down world
yeah i'm going to use debt that is my
friend that is my friend that is my
friend dave ramsey and the ramsey people
are crazy well that's cause you're
selling a course on nothing down real
estate a get rich quick crap
and it's not gonna get rich quick it's
get rich you know you'll get rich i got
rich i had a million dollar net worth at
25 years old 26 years old made 200
dollars but i lost it all because of
that
and uh because i was following
these guys that are running around on
the internet today screaming they're not
on the internet in those days but they
were in hotel ballrooms you know so um
you know the guy that wrote the book
nothing down robert allen went chapter
11. okay i mean so this just tells you
you know it and not matter robert and
you know he just he believed that stuff
but uh but it's just
you know so you you have to decide which
of these paths you're going to follow
and and i defy you to find a
someone that has followed the get rich
quick nothing down real estate
the um
uh cash is bad
idea that if you know that those guys if
i defy you to find someone that's
followed that strategy and 20 years
later still owns a bunch of real estate
they just don't there's a correlation
between you getting rich slow and then
keeping that wealth and you getting rich
quick and then losing it all exactly
exactly
and if someone has to flop around and
phone with the mouth to get you to do
their stuff
then
run the other way thou doth protest too
loudly
young man you know shakespeare right
there seriously this is the ramsay show
[Music]
uh
[Music]
still on baby step number one
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage shane
and kelly are with us hey guys how are
you good you're doing great how about
you better than i deserve welcome you
guys it's so good to have you where do
you live we are in mechanicsburg
pennsylvania right outside our capitol
very good up in the harrisburg area very
good good to have you guys and all the
way to nashville to do a debt-free
scream how much have you paid off so we
got rid of 229 000 cash flowing 109 000
in 16 months
whoa
what was your range of income during
that time we started out at 81 000 and
increased to 132 000 and then any
stimulus or child tax credit went right
to our debt right cool did you sell
something big too you had to
that is part of our story okay all right
well tell us your story what happened
so in 2014 i got out of physical therapy
school i graduated with my doctorate in
physical therapy
and so we had over 200 thousand dollars
in student loans
and at that point i went on pinterest
and started looking up ideas of how to
get out of debt and i found the baby
steps and in the same week my little
sister mentioned dave ramsey so i read
the complete guide money in two days
total money makeover in two days oh my
gosh and we attended fpu game on yes we
got gazelle intense at that time but
then we decided to start a family and
shane became a stay-at-home dad at that
point
and
won the pandemic hit in 2020 the
hospital i work for was offering a ton
of overtime so um i worked from 3am to
7am and then went to my full-time job
until 4 and then shane went to work from
4 30 p.m to 1am wow so we worked around
the clock wow
but you were making bank yes so that was
that's not that was not 132. you made a
lot more than 132 that year yeah
that was our taxes for last year but oh
it was with all that work yep all that
work but we lived on nothing basically
nothing
i mean when i when we went gazelle
intense like we relied on christmas for
people to give us like underwear and
socks
that's how like
we wanted to get it done so
okay but you said you paid off 229 in 16
months yes making 132. that doesn't work
nope so the other part of our story is
the debt was our suv our student loans
at that point then we're about 100 in
the 100 000 range and then we own two
houses right next to each other and our
long-term plan was to combine the two
houses um but getting enough debt was
more important to us so we decided to
sell the smaller of the two houses
that got rid of the 89 000 mortgage and
then we put the twenty nine thousand
dollar profit to our student loans oh
okay now my numbers are working good
okay
well good for you was it worth it
it definitely was i mean you know it was
just a struggle
i would say like when we first got
married because it was just like you
know we were throwing money away and
just money would go here vacations and
now it's just you know we have that
money now and
at the time it was a struggle yeah yeah
i mean we're probably only making like i
would say eight thousand dollars a year
maybe when we first started that we got
married like 12 years ago but we found
we found you in about 2014 and then went
gazelle intense in 2020. okay so where
did this come from it sounds like just
overnight it was like a 180.
yeah well like i said we knew about you
and we were gazelle intense before
children and then we kind of went davish
and
um and then in 2020 with the pandemic we
didn't have anything else to do and like
i said my hospital offered so much
overtime so i was able to pick that up
yeah there were other other side jobs
that we had just like babysitting dogs i
mean we sold everything that we owned
yeah everything i mean the kids really
did think that they were going to be
next so i'm wondering if uh because of
all the opportunity for extra work you
mathematically could see that we can do
this and that got you back to intensity
yeah the hope the hope made you go again
yeah yeah so you went from gazelle to
dave ish or ramsay-ish
and then but then when you saw hey we
could pick up this work and finish this
and you got the game on again yeah yep
come on all right i'm starting to
understand what happened good
very good way to go you guys all right
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt
is i would say hard work
dedication i mean you really have to put
in the time like if you want something
you got to go for it and that was
something that we wanted to change our
you know our family tree and for our
kids to have a better life so and i'm
glad that we did it and we followed the
steps
i'd say work as well work work work work
around the clock um and also having a
strong y um i appreciate that anthony
o'neil says if your y doesn't make you
cry the price of commitment will so
having our strong y our boys um
and then also staying connected to the
podcast and the baby steps facebook
group i think we're really beneficial
staying motivated on the plan and it
sounds like the kids were a big driver
for why this life change was happening
you wanted them to live in a debt-free
home live a debt-free life and have
opportunities you didn't have yes yes
wow
so you paid off the student loans you
sold the house next door did that
include your mortgage you paid off no
not yet so you're debt-free but the
mortgage yep grand baby steps four five
and six perfect good for you well done
well done i'm so proud of you guys thank
you who were your biggest cheerleaders
um our good friends christina and klaus
they attended fpu with us and cheered us
along the way and our families yeah of
course of course and each other
for sure
well i'm telling you you guys put in the
hours i mean these 80 90 hour weeks
you're talking about here were real
and uh that's that's crazy you can do
that for a short period of time
if you work like no one else later you
get to work like no one else too you
have to work whenever you want if you
don't have any stinking payments yeah
that's actually part of our story too um
since we paid off the debt i was able to
go part-time as a physical therapist and
now i'm home with the boys during the
day and then shane works full-time um
during the day so we get to spend so
much more time together ah very good
yeah you got your life back yes
definitely did you stole it back from
sally mae yeah yeah you stole it and you
stole it back wow yes
what do you tell that person who's got
200 000 in student loans and they're
going well i'll wait for someone to
forgive it
yeah just do it get it done work work
work work
as hard as you can because it's so
freeing to be debt-free and you can do
what you want yeah and we didn't rely on
anybody else it was just us doing it you
know we weren't going to sit around and
wait for somebody just to give us a
check and you know pay it off but i'm so
glad that we did it and we put in the
hours and we're here amen amen good job
well done all right we got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you because
for sure that is the next chapter in
your story and an extra copy of total
money makeover for you to give away to
someone and completely cause a ruckus
love your t-shirts cash is king live
like no one else and you brought the
kiddos with you let's bring them in what
are their names and ages we have roman
he's four and hudson is two and the
t-shirts say i am a why
oh that's so great
i am why i'm sorry i said it wrong oh
well done you guys that's beautiful very
fun cute kids very very fun all right
shane and kelly roman and hudson from
pennsylvania 100 are 229 000 paid off in
16 months making 81 to 132. count it
down let's hear a debt free scream
here's the baby number three
we're dead friends
[Music]
[Applause]
wow that's how to do it make your baby
announcement to millions of listeners
while you're at it i think grandma and
grandpa sit on the sidelines this may
have been the first time they just heard
that i'm not sure but looking at the
reactions it's a possibility
did that is that the first time you did
it you just told it for the first time
all right
they're verifying through the glass now
awesomeness very cool that's a lot of
fun that's inspiring yeah very inspiring
so i mean that's a lot of debt i
couldn't make those numbers work for a
minute uh but you know what happens when
people start working like that
uh and they start going whatever it
takes whatever it takes or we'll sell
the house we'll sell that house next
door whatever it takes got to work 80
hours whatever it takes once you start
saying whatever it takes and you mean it
you can make that go away there's
nothing you're not willing to do but as
long as you start going now wait a
minute tell me about the uh
is there what this is what little one
little thing and this is a little angle
and as long as you're trying to figure
out some way to scheme and scam it's not
gonna work no shortcuts here just hard
work yeah it's whatever it is
whatever it takes people change their
lives when they finally say
i've
had it
i'm sick and tired
of being sick and tired
that's when you'll change
and not until this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today lucia is with us in
virginia hi lucia how are you
good thank you
good how can we help today
yes um i
i'm wondering if i should get uh or
consider a trust for my elderly mother
she's going to be selling her home
and
moving in with us
so the proceeds i'm kind of nervous
about it i want to do the best for her
protect those proceeds
so um
i've heard of a medicare trust and
different types of trust but i don't
know
where to go with that
what are you protecting the proceeds
from
well from
other siblings that might
you know inconsiderate siblings that
might call
every time they have a problem and then
my mother would
you know dwindle uh sounds like that's
not a hypothetical
no
[Laughter]
we already know who this is they have a
name okay
asking for a friend yeah yeah
yes
um
wow
if you put it into a trust and she is
the
beneficial
has the beneficial interest of the trust
that means she's the owner of the assets
and the trust in a sense
um
and you set
someone that will say no to
inconsiderate siblings
up as the trustee
your mom would still have the power to
instruct the trustee to release the
funds
okay there's no way
if your mom can access the funds which
she would need to do
if she needed them right
then she can access them and give them
away
and um so
you know i i think what we're gonna do
you know you could put some
you could put the money with her
permission into an account that requires
your signature
and her signature
and you could refuse to give that
signature but if you hired a
professional trustee they won't refuse
if you set yourself up as the trustee
now you could say no mom i'm not going
to do it
but you're going to end up being the bad
guy with the inconsiderate
parasite sibling
you probably are anyway aren't you
uh
yes
well i mean generally the responsible
one is the bad guy of the parasite
that's generally the way it works in
families i mean yeah have you talked to
your mom about this had this
conversation with her
um no no not really i wanted to get um
you know and for in the information and
then present it to her of what you know
the options are yeah i think what i
would do is make sure that she has a
good estate plan and while you're
meeting with the estate plan attorney
ask them what some legal methodologies
are
to make it difficult for your mom to
access the money in a moment of weakness
uh in a moment of enabling to a parasite
sibling
and just talk talk out loud in front of
her to the to the estate planner about
that they could probably tell you if
there's a way to structure a trust to do
that and you could meld that into the
estate plan that's one thing to do you
can set up simple bank account that
requires both signatures
that's not a trust
but it just requires both signatures
yours and hers and you're not gonna give
it
uh that one's very clean
if you're going to set up a trust the
trustee would need to be someone who
would say no
and again an attorney is not going to
say no they're going to take the
instruction
of the person that has the beneficial
interest
um
they're going to be uncomfortable
otherwise and you're just going to look
at her and say no
no you can't do that mom because you're
going to need this money i don't need
the money but you're going to need this
money to take care of you
and uh
you know so
that's the two things that come to mind
um
and uh
no matter how uh it is structured
whatever you decide to do with her input
and maybe with the input of the attorney
i think you go ahead and have a little
uh a little town hall meeting here with
the spout with the other siblings and
say listen here's what we've done
this is mom's money and nobody can get
to it except her we've trapped it
so that kind of puts them on notice
don't even ask because it's useless for
you to ask
and then you're not put in the position
later
that says oh i'm the one that has to say
no but if you just act like hey we put
it in a lock box a legal lock box and it
can't be opened
so you can't get it and just let them
know to don't bother and i i do that as
a conversation i'll head them off at the
pass thing
and put it put it in the rearview mirror
but that's not an unusual thing you're
facing by the way
um
parasite siblings with an enabling mom
uh is is a fairly standard
playbook we see out there a lot creates
a lot of relational drama especially
when you don't have this conversation
and all of a sudden mom's gone we're all
trying to fight about it now so i like
having the conversation now
yep
david is in new mexico hi david how are
you
hey dave hey george thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
so uh my wife and i we've really been
committing to going through the baby
steps
and right now we are
doing baby step four
and um
great what i want to know
what i wanted to know was was when you
guys thought would be a good time
or a good baby step to start thinking
about a baby
so we're at that point where we're
considering it
um i don't really like uh public schools
in our area so i want to send them to
private school
uh
do you guys have any suggestions as far
as when to start thinking about that
yesterday or
you should already have babies go get
babies babies are awesome
okay what's holding you back right now
well so the main thing is to both my
wife my work
she's a labor and delivery nurse which
probably explains why she's really
wanting the baby
so
my concern is once she has our our first
baby that i would really like for her to
be able to stay home uh that's going to
have a shift in our income yep and so i
don't want us to have to take any steps
backwards since we've been able to move
forward so well you shouldn't have to
stay accepted back where's your
structure your household to where you
live on your income
can you afford to live on your income
alone david today
um
so so the biggest issue would be the
mortgage um you know we we took on the
the mortgage
prior to the whole you know dave ramsey
baby steps uh you know so it's a little
bit more than our uh that portion of our
income
so right now at my current income that
probably
might be feasible but we would
definitely have to do the whole beans
and rice rice and beans again
um
you know so well it may be that you you
choose to not live in that house to have
babies
or you choose to not live in that house
to have babies in her be at home with
them
or she works um you know three twelfths
which a lot of which a lot of nurses do
and a newborn's not going to private
school so we don't need to worry about
that right now either
at least not in my house no
do they have private schools for
newborns
yeah oh boy yeah the uh um they got
everything for newborns but yeah
listen we don't tell people when to have
children uh it's not a financial step
the baby steps have nothing to do with
babies
and so um you know you have babies when
you and god decide to have babies and
that's that's the time to have babies
and i'm a big fan of babies yeah and it
becomes a line item in your budget
that's it yeah it's an attitude you know
and so what you're doing uh
david is you're you're saying okay
i really want my cake and eat it too i
want to live in this house i want to go
to private schools i want her to not
have to work
and i want us to uh
you know to to
prosper and go forward and you can't
have all that you're gonna have to
choose something your income's gonna
have to go up
she's gonna have to maintain some kind
of income
or you're gonna live in a different
house
or or or
and thus is the joy of raising a family
but um yeah i i highly recommend it
anyway yesterday
it's uh it's the babies are the best
thing i've ever done and i've done some
really cool things but babies are the
best the only thing better than the
babies of course is the grand babies
and um if i'd have known how great grand
babies were i'd been nicer to their
parents so there you go rachel and
daniel and denise they ended up just
fine they they turned out they're gonna
turn it off it's it's okay but yeah it's
because of their mom this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your jobs
your relationships your mental wellness
your career your money your life it's
all right here on
the ramsey show thank you so much for
joining us america open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
jd is with us in philadelphia hi jd how
are you
hi guys how you doing
thank you better than we deserve what's
up
okay so
i wanna know how to officially buy my
family business
how do you what
officially buy my family business buy it
yes so you who owns it
my parents own it i'm technically on
paper we're all 33 percent
owners
uh one-third one-third one-third your
mom and dad have 33 each
well yeah yes though
i mean
or they have together they have 67 and
you have 33. together they have yeah
together they have okay they're that
that part of it i'm on as a third who
operates the business
um
they do
but i do
so i do everything i do
i measure i install i quote i
order
i invoice i do everything
um
they're
they just you know they're there to
assist me
and
what do they do when they are assisting
you
uh so my father he gives me a hand
just uh
you know keeps helping me with the glass
and everything when we install so
you're installing you're in the glass
business
yeah we do showers and
storefronts okay so your dad acts as
labor
correct but he's the he's the owner
i got that part but his day job during
the day he doesn't do anything except as
to help you lift something
correct
you do you run it so it's a one-man
operation basically with one laborer
correct
so not much of a business
uh no it's it's a two-person business we
brought in
a
quarter of a million last year yeah top
line what'd your net yeah
uh 160 no you didn't
yeah not only not on two and a quarter
in the glass business you didn't
so i i was able to
figure out how to save a lot of money
on different parts and materials and
source them cheaper than others
in the history of the glass business
maybe but no i don't i'm sorry your
margins are not that big your cost of
goods sold has to be bigger than that
i'm talking about net profit that you
paid taxes on you made a hundred and
sixty thousand dollars net profit
taxable income on two and a quarter oh
no no no you didn't right okay okay
because they were you know other
just material income yes sorry for
materials and
not for
sorry not with uh
not paying everybody
not paying materials yeah okay so what
did you net
that you paid taxes on
um everything who was that
120
they pay taxes on
oh
i'm 35. okay
all right
um i don't think there's a business here
to be bought
okay it's a one-man operation here's
what i'm here here's what i'm up against
okay
we coach people in small business and in
leadership uh ten thousand different
businesses in america right now
and so we talk about this all the time
buying out the parents in a succession
plan and so forth but a business in
order for it to have value has to be
able to pay all the players involved
meaning you and so if i wanted to buy
this business i would have to hire
someone that does everything you do
by the time i do that
my net profit is going to be very close
to zero
you follow me
yeah
i mean if i hire a skilled
technician
i hire someone that's doing estimating
i hire a manager maybe some of these
people have two jobs and they maybe the
manager is the skilled technician i
don't care but there's two or three
people involved and i add that payroll
to this profit and loss statement your
net profit at that point would be close
to zero which means and it's not a
negative thing but it means there's not
a business to buy that you basically own
your job
which is not unusual for a one-man show
and it's not a bad thing but there's no
way to place a value on the business
itself because you would never buy a job
okay
okay so then i i think your mom and dad
uh you know
you guys need to just decide what you're
gonna do because you could just stop
tomorrow
drive across the street
with your tools
and start the same exact business
and make the same exact money next year
and be 100 owner you follow me
yeah
so your mom that means your mom and dad
don't own anything as far as the
business itself goes now your dad may
have grown this business and handed it
off to you at this point and you want to
honor him with something and if you want
to do that that's fine
but uh i you know i'd say 20 grand 50
grand or something and you just pay him
that over two years
out of your income
and uh they let you go but it's not
worth any more than that it's probably
not even really worth that technically
right you see how i'm getting you see
how i'm arriving at that conclusion it's
not it's not putting down the quality of
your work it's not putting down the the
fact that your dad's worked hard all
these years it's not putting down what
you're doing but there's no math left
over in this equation
you're kind of buying the client list
and the name of the company and the
brand and the equity that exists in that
outside of that you've got to do the
work right
so have you had a conversation with your
parents about this are they looking to
let go of this business
they are looking to let go but they
don't know how to let go
they're always just involved i i try to
say let me take it over yeah
i'll give you a percentage of
you know do they need the money i'll
give you 50 i'll give you 50 of the
profit for two years
you know and dad we've got to wrap this
up because i'm otherwise i'm going to
have to move on and do something else
right
and i love you and you'll always be my
dad but this business part of this is
not working for me anymore
so we've got to have a set plan that you
and i can both agree to
that is uh that's good for you guys and
good for me
i can
hypothetically i just walk across the
street and start the same business
tomorrow and i'd be 100 owner and next
year i'd make 120 000 in my pocket and i
you know there's nobody just no i'd be
the owner because really you could right
you know how to do you know how to do
this business
because the only thing he's doing is
holding one into the shower door
because he's handed everything off else
off to you
over the years he probably used to do
what you do but over the years he's
handed it off to you
and now he doesn't work in the business
anymore and so i need to buy you guys
out we need to wrap this up
because what's happening is your mom
keeps running her mouth and stepping in
here and telling you how to do what you
already know how to do and you're like
wanting to be a grown man and stuff and
that's what's going on here and so this
has become a mama thing or a daddy thing
or something like that and so you just
got to draw it to a close gently kindly
with a smile
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech
you could be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
well we all know time is important it's
more precious than money or shiny toys
if you could do one thing that would
make the time you have left worthwhile
wouldn't you do it
of course you would we all get that
and we want you to have everything you
need to be
well
and that's why we're partnering with the
folks at betterhelp to give you a month
of free one-on-one weekly therapy when
you pre-order a copy of dr john dolone's
new book own your past change your
future
yeah you buy a book you get a month of
free therapy with better health that's a
deal
uh you're never too old or too young to
improve your health and make your
relationship stronger this is
life-changing combo listen his new book
comes out next tuesday if you want the
pre-order deals you need to order it now
and this book is incredible it'll make
you laugh and cry it has affected
everyone who's read it george i'm super
pumped about this and i'm about to
listen to the audiobook i got my hard
copy last night got the audiobook about
to go on a road trip for easter okay
gonna really dig into it okay well i i
of course read it when it was in
manuscript level and i i find myself i i
love when we do a book that uh even
those of us that are hardcore writers
and speakers and stuff around here we
get a lump in our throat oh man that's
yeah
really and that's that's what this one
is it's like dr john sitting across from
you reading your mind the way he has the
ability to do his decades of experience
and phd's and he brings it down to even
my level dave which is that's hard to do
into that conversational
well my level as well my brother all
right get the free therapy sessions the
ebook the audiobook if you pre-order own
your past change your future only twenty
dollars at ramseysolutions.com
do it quick because the book comes out
next week and all that's going to go
away the books it's just going to be a
book then
that's the book just going to be just
buying a book after that so now this is
this is the biggest offering we've ever
had with a book on preschool i've never
seen anything like it it's pretty
bizarre it's pretty cool kimberly is
with us kimberly's in chicago hi
kimberly how are you
hi good afternoon thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
uh well i am a teacher and i currently
have a mutual fund through my
b
and i'm wanting to know how should i
allocate my assets within the fund if
the small and mid-cap fund are combined
the small and mid-cap are combined
yes so there's there's like a large cap
small or mid cap that's together
then there's international
fixed income and then there's other and
the other is like a target date fund
how's the track records look on them
um they're above the
the smp
okay
all three of them
the large smaller man and international
yes i'm not really familiar with the
fixed
income no i would not do the fix that's
going to be a low producing
fund that's like a guaranteed fund we
stay away from that one okay but um
i guess you're across those three if
they've got good long track records
okay um and you can just either go
thirds or you could uh double up on the
small mid cap since it's confiscating
two of the categories
i don't know george washington sounds
like it sounds like you're diversified
across a lot of different types and so
that's the key here uh versus the exact
percentages
but if you don't have any other options
is that all you have in there yeah i was
just
yes but i was just thinking about going
between the three because that's what
made sense to me
um but i i just wasn't sure so that's
why i called yeah well there's not a
magic formula so you you could do that
or you could say i'm gonna put 50 in the
one that's got two categories right and
25 and the other two but you're going to
come out okay
in either one of those equations you're
going to be fine does your 403 b have
the a roth option to it
it if it does i'm not aware but i have a
roth ira elsewhere okay and that's in
that's in good mutual funds as well
well ask about your 403b a lot of them
are now offering a roth option and i
would take it if you can get it
i would definitely convert to that
that's probably a more important
discussion than the actual fund
distribution
because it's going to grow tax free
very important scott's with us in
atlanta
i
if i can find the button here scott hey
scott what's up
hey dave george nice to speak to you
guys you too how can we help
uh so in december uh i was let go from
my uh job had for almost a decade
and in january i formed an llc
and um now doing my own thing so for you
thank you um it took me about six weeks
i started calling myself a
re-electropreneur because i didn't
really want to do it but you know there
i was
um it took me about six weeks to get to
uh replacing
my income with the revenue that the
company was billing so that was pretty
quick
but uh i've always worked for somebody
else i'm just an employee here also i
guess
uh so i don't know how much to pay
myself
is it just you
it's just me i i have a contractor
that's helping me with something else
but
i've uh it's just me and i've got all
this revenue and i don't know
how much you know for me as an employee
how to pay myself i'm on baby step two
i know how to how much i need to make my
monthly budget
but above that i don't know how much
more
i should be paying myself if that makes
sense sure
all right what i would do is always set
up a separate checking account for your
llc i assume you did that
i did and all of your income from the
llc goes into that and only expenses
come out of that is that right
correct you don't buy groceries out of
that checking account
absolutely not okay good all right and
so then the only other question is how
much money
it sounds like you're doing uh some kind
of service based thing what do you do
uh public relations it's a pr firm okay
all right
and so you're just basically get either
one-time gigs or put get retainers one
of the two right
that's right it's it's almost
exclusively retainer okay all right
that's great good plan
does that help stabilize the income so
that's that's very good so how much uh
do you need to put back into the
business
uh
not a lot really
my my overhead is pretty low i bought
myself a new computer that's about it
yeah but i mean you don't have to say
you know i've got to replenish inventory
because there's not any you you this is
all just sweat you've done this with a
you know hustle and grind right
correct yeah good job way to go
so what have you how much have you
brought in
uh let's see i started playing
officially in uh in the end of february
march
um so right now i've got about 30 grand
sitting in the businesses account
um
i was fortunate that i had a few months
of severance that floated me until uh
the end of march yeah so nicely played
well thank you so here's the thing the
only thing you need retained earnings
for
is to cover future expenses that cash
flow won't cover
which is virtually nil
and so i you know if i'm in your shoes
based on the numbers you're giving me
i'm gonna set about five grand in that
checking account not go below that but
i'm gonna draw down to that every month
okay
that's helpful to know now what about uh
what about taxes and
you know all that stuff because i know
that uh as as an llc as an s corp i'm
paying myself a certain amount for um
for as a salary and that's taxed one way
and then um i'm drawing
on the remainder so that's taxed a
different way if you're if the salary
has a withholding on it if you set
yourself up on a w-2
then the other portion is the only
portion we will need to address and that
is set aside a fourth of it
in a separate savings account so if you
pull 10 000 bucks out set 2 500 aside in
a separate savings account because once
a quarter you're going to need to pay
quarterly estimates
on your draws
right
and if you got if you got a fourth you
can probably cover it up up to about 200
000 worth of income and you may be above
200 000 worth of income when you're done
here it maybe you have to increase that
a little bit but it's going to be
somewhere around a fourth it's going to
get you real close
and that's where i'd start anyway and
just every time i draw money out in the
old days i just set aside a fourth set
aside a fourth over in a separate
savings account pretend like it wasn't
there it was a withholding account in a
sense for the irs because i was going to
have to pay it once a quarter yeah and
work with the tax pro if you've got
questions about this you want to know
how to allocate it properly that's what
i'd be doing yeah check the elps at
ramseysolutions.com for endorsed local
providers for taxes they can help you
with that they can also help you set up
a little simple set of books
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
thank you for joining us folks if you
have questions
about going to college debt-free
how to go to college and pay cash for it
if you're a parent or a student and you
want to talk about that
we're going to be doing a segment or two
on that in the upcoming weeks and we'd
love to include your question your call
on that subject
go to ramseysolutions.com ask put
college in the subject line
tell us your question and kelly will be
in touch with you
we can schedule you into that segment in
the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage ryan and sarah are with
us hey guys how are you good how are you
better than we deserve man welcome where
do you guys live we're from wausau
alaska oh wow that's a bit of a haul a
long way yeah all right well cool it's a
beautiful town i've been there a lot of
fun up there
yeah we uh uh well thanks for coming
down how much debt have you paid off so
we've paid off 745 000
over the course of about 13 years wow
[Laughter]
what a journey i love this okay and your
range of income during that 13 years so
we were newlyweds we're just starting
out we started about 75 000 and now 280.
wow what do you guys do for a living i'm
a firefighter and sarah's an interior
designer wow well i'm guessing your
house is paid for with this yes sir so
we're looking at weird people absolutely
yeah what's this house worth
so probably about 9.50 in this real
estate market
so you're easily baby steps millionaires
then yes congratulations very cool how
old are you two 38 wow look at you
this is awesome you're so weird
very well done very well done all right
now this is a long ramsey journey 13
years
tell us this story yes sir well you can
imagine a lot of problems get solved
around fire station tables and we talked
about money and i had heard about you
but we were living large we had a lake
boat
yukon cars and we were just living with
no contentment
and
sarah explained that she wanted to stay
home when we were expecting our first
which was max
and we couldn't do it you know i did the
budget and i was looking at the numbers
and it was just terrifying to know that
we didn't even have the option and there
was no contentment there so i kind of
did it wrong i came home after listening
to your book the total money makeover
was ready to sell her yukon
wow that's always the answer so mom's
car yeah
so we did we got on the same page we
took the 13-week fpu class
sold the yukon sold my truck and sold
the lake boat
and that started the journey and we
moved out of a custom home that we were
in and got into a fixer-upper
and we both talked about that that's
when we really learned about contentment
and really started following the steps
and that's where we you know life just
started happening along the way we fixed
that house up we have five kids we went
through three adoptions
and
then we were able to buy a lot and build
our dream house on the lake
but you know we couldn't even use before
you know we sold the boat we couldn't
afford
we were stressed out about gas we were
stressed out we had this custom home
when we first got married and we
couldn't even afford to put a lawn in
wow so it was a long journey wow way to
go impressive
very cool so what made up the 745
so 75 000 was the two vehicles in the
boat and then the rest was mortgage debt
paying off the fixer-upper and then
paying off the home that we're in now
wow very cool
so uh sarah the the
the trade-off was you're looking at it
you're going i get to stay home but
without a yukon right
[Laughter]
is that that is that how it worked that
was yeah that was a hard decision
but we knew it was the right decision i
remember going to the bank
to sell it and i i mean i was like i
think eight months pregnant or seven
months pregnant but i sat there signing
the papers like crying
but it was like once we ripped that
band-aid off and you know went and
bought a car that we could afford to pay
for in cash and
just got started and started making
those tough decisions
the piece was almost immediate it just
kept coming and waves and waves and
it definitely gave us motivation to keep
going we had friends that
thought we were crazy like aren't you
guys going backwards you had this you
know custom house and
this flashy lake boat and you know
fancy cars i mean we thought they were
fancy but um
you know we sold all of that got
beaters and
downgraded into a house that had pink
wallpaper everywhere and
i mean it was and it was just like we
don't care like we're we're on board and
and we
have a goal and we're just going to go
for it so
it doesn't feel like stepping back at
all right because you can see where
you're going exactly yeah no discipline
seems pleasant at the time but it yields
a harvest of righteousness right we're
living like no one else so that yeah
later we can live and give like no one
else
now you're in a position to do anything
you want to do with five kiddos
including adopt way to go guys that's
heroes you guys are incredible so 13
years most people would just be
unwilling to do that what carried you
guys through when it got hard and you
went gosh we're in year seven how much
longer is this going to be
um
honestly i think one of the biggest
things that helped us just stay
um motivated but inspired like
just keeping um things around us that
would keep us inspired to keep going so
we taught fpu i think five times wow
but we pretty early on started listening
to the podcast
every day i mean
if we were in the car it was on at home
it was on ryan would listen to it on his
way to work i mean our kids can
pretty much like answer a lot of the
questions
and they i mean when we get in the car
yeah you and max forgot the next segment
sadly that might be a much better show
i'm worried
that's awesome but yeah so they were all
engaged and on board and
it was just
yeah that was really inspirational just
to always be hearing
people's stories and
you know and then we would talk about it
a lot
what you know what is that going to look
like when we're debt-free and what can
we do and
so now that you're here
does it feel like you thought it was
going to feel
it
it feels surreal like it's just crazy
pulling up here today like we've talked
about it for so long um
i don't know if ryan wants to share but
we so we paid off the house a number of
months ago and had planned to do this
trip and after we paid it off we ended
up having a house fire oh no
so
um and a fireman has a house but wow oh
this is awful yeah
how about a fire um pretty much the
third level is
gutted down to the studs um the whole
house had smoke damage so we actually
aren't living in it right now we had to
move out
and are are dealing with um the
insurance insurance and all that so
we've joked around that you know we're
going to get to
move back into our dream house twice you
know for a second time
but we're um
we're really excited about it and
moving back in hopefully sooner rather
than later but just even going through
that whole process
the stress and everything
i mean it was definitely stressful but
knowing that you know we didn't have a
house payment to make in the middle of
it and fight with the insurance company
over that and we had an emergency fund
to pay for
you know the down payment for a rental
to move into and
just buying some clothes and stuff for
everyone like all of that
didn't have to be stressful because we
were prepared and so
that was huge wow
yeah yeah it was really nice to be able
to
you know having being a firefighter and
having a house fire you always see the
other side of it yeah but going through
it and seeing the kids and being able to
just take care of their needs and just
constantly focusing on this goal of just
having a biblical mindset towards money
and following that that path gave us
that security in that moment and
it was it was really good well let's
pull the kiddos in what are their names
in ages so we have max he's 13 presley
14.
blake is eight and josh is six all right
very good stuff from alaska ryan and
sarah 745 000 paid off in 13 years 100
debt free house and everything count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream three
two one we're debt-free
[Music]
[Applause]
wow this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today
[Music]
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five our question of
the day comes from blinds.com they have
a 100
satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismeasure you pick
the wrong color they'll remake your
blinds for free free samples free
shipping new promos all the time
you'll save even more always use the
promo code the magic word ramsay
today's question comes from evan in
michigan he says i'm 34 years old and i
earn over 300 dollars a year working in
software engineering i've always thought
that roth 401ks are the way to go for
retirement savings however due to my
income amount wouldn't it be better to
defer the taxes until retirement when
income is more likely to be lower or pay
the taxes at my current rate my thought
process is that my wife and i will
likely live on significantly less in
retirement so wouldn't it make more
sense to pay the taxes then
it's a good question
well it is um the the problem is that
the um
tax rates are not stable
they change with the political winds
and so you can't use that set of
assumptions to work because they might
just look up and go oh anybody who saved
a million dollars or more
gets taxed double because they're evil
and they must be punished and there is
that whole group of people out there
that want that kind of tax law enacted i
don't think it'll happen i hope it
doesn't happen but it could happen
that's the problem number one with that
theory
the other thing that happens is when you
have everything in a roth it's 100
tax-free
under current law you do not have to
deal with the required minimum
distributions
you're not required to pull the money
out and so it can just sit there
continue to grow and grow you've got a
lot more flexibility you can pull it all
out you can pull none of it out it's tax
free and so you don't have to touch it
so it gives you a lot more flexibility
my
tax rate
could go down hypothetically where i'd
have quit working i
don't know if it would or not really but
it could
and um
yet i have 100 of mine in a roth
i've conv what traditional stuff i had
from the old days i've converted it to
roth and paid the taxes
because of the flexibility because
likely in my case and maybe even in your
k7 a lot of it because you're making so
much money you've done so well
congratulations
is you're probably not going to touch
this money
i doubt i'll ever touch my roths they'll
probably become part of an inheritance
i don't need i won't need them i've got
real estate income that i'd have i'd
have other types of other sources other
things going on so i probably would just
let all of that sit there and grow and
grow and grow and grow and grow and grow
or if it's in a traditional
it has required minimum distribution
they're forcing you to take certain
amounts out
yeah and there's a lot of assumptions
here that 30 years from now the tax
brackets won't change or they won't go
significantly higher and i just don't
like that having to assume all of those
things i like the guaranteed when i put
my after-tax dollars in today it's going
to grow tax-free if i've got 2 million
sitting in that roth when i retire i can
pull 2 million out tax-free exactly
let's me sleep at night so i'm i'm i'm
still doing i mean i'm doing what i'm
saying i personally do a roth
and i'm saying and you know and i'm and
i'm in the same situation and george is
in the same situation as well so
uh he's probably in a closer situation
to you than i am because age is similar
that kind of a thing so
well done evan well done man we
appreciate you uh writing in and being
part of our blinds.com question of the
day
matt is in pittsburgh hey matt welcome
to the ramsay show
hey dave it's an honor to be speaking
with you today you too what's up
um well i'm currently a 22 year old
college student um i'll be graduating
here in the next couple months and i'm
looking to get out of my renting
situation and purchase a home within the
next year
i'm kind of lost on
how to really save up for it if i should
be keeping all my um
like income that i'm going to be having
in cash or if i should be investing it
and how much you recommend to put down
on my first home purchase i'm just kind
of looking for some guidance here cool
so what's your income matt
um well currently i don't have any but
i'll be starting a job in june that i'll
be making uh 70 000 in my first year
plus um 10k in stock but i'm pretty sure
i don't get paid that until like a year
year and a half okay
and do you have any debt right now
um i have i have a good amount of
savings and personal investments but i
do have nine thousand dollars left on a
car payment okay and that's all the debt
that's all did that so what's stopping
you from paying off the car today
and freeing up that payment um
i well i um
i i was fortunate enough not to have to
pay for my college because i got an
athletic scholarship so
because of that um my dad we bought a
car together well it's in my name but we
bought it together during covid so
there's
no interest on it it was like one of
those deals i know
you probably won't like hearing that but
i don't know i just haven't put it as a
first priority just because i don't
really want to use my um i have about
like 11 000 in savings right now and i
kind of don't have an income these next
couple months so i've just been avoiding
it i guess how much have you gotten
personal investments
um around 17
okay and is that in a retirement account
no it's actually in individual stocks
and yeah basically all stocks and a
little bit of cryptocurrency
okay well matt i'll tell you what we
teach and this is the process i followed
to get through all the baby steps and
now with a paid for house baby step one
is a thousand dollar emergency fund baby
step two we pay off all of our debt
using the debt snowball method and that
includes the car baby step three we get
three to six months of expenses and an
emergency fund and then
baby step three b we start saving up for
the house
and so that's where that would fall in
and so you're not quite there yet you
could be
if we released these investments cashed
out and started doing things a different
way
but it sounds like you're you're good
with matt's plan which is fine but if
you're gonna buy a house here's our
parameters for it in that 3b i want you
to save up 10 to 20
for your down payment on a 15-year fixed
mortgage that should be your only option
when it comes to mortgages and the take
your uh payment on that should be no
more than a quarter of your take-home
pay
and so you can jump onto our mortgage
calculator ramseysolutions.com and start
playing around with those numbers
to see hey in the pittsburgh area for a
reasonable house for me for you know my
first house what do i need to do okay i
need to save up seventy thousand dollars
in order to get this house on a 15-year
fixed rate where the payment's no more
than a quarter of my take-home pay
gotcha i'm at your so once i pay off the
car
sorry what was that go ahead go ahead
so once once i pay off the car and save
enough for to put 20 percent down and my
take on pay it's um my monthly payments
a quarter of my take-home pay then i'm
good to go
on a 15 year yeah and you could i mean
today if you paid off the car you'd
still have money left over for your
emergency fund and then you can start to
save up for this down payment we just
got to start doing things in the right
order so that you feel this progress
gotcha okay so here's the thing
um
you've listened to this show i can tell
by the way you're responding to some of
these things
and you kind of knew what we were going
to say didn't you
yeah a little bit
all right and so
here's the data
the actual facts
not theory
not a ramsey opinion
but the actual facts
we did the largest study
of millionaires ever done in north
america 10 167 of them
the number of them that became
millionaires using bitcoin was precisely
zero
the number of them that used single
stocks playing
a day trader game
was
under 5
in other words 95 of them did not use
your plan
right
so you need to decide if your plan sucks
as bad as i think it does
well would you recommend cashing out of
my individual stocks in crypto and
keeping that apparently
apparently that's what i just told you
so don't invest that in anything else
keep it sitting in cash
you need an emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses and you need to
be debt-free paying off that stupid car
by the end of the day
and then you start then you start
building in cash
your down payment on your house
and then when you get your house you
start putting 15 percent of your income
away into good growth stock mutual funds
in your 401k at your new great job and
you're going to be a millionaire doing
that by the time you're 35
and you're gonna have your house paid
off by the time you're 35
if
you follow
what we teach
that is a proven
process a proven plan that data backs up
it's not doing what your broke friends
all think is sexy while you guys are
playing beer pong
this is what is really done by real
millionaires
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
it's a free call at triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
george is the host of one of the ramsey
networks productions called a podcast
called fine print and one of the very
first episodes in the first season
of fine print george pretty much exposed
turgot turbo tax as lying
when they said
that they were letting you file your
taxes for free
george it appears you have stirred up a
problem i was a fortune teller a prophet
no i think i think you uh i think you
stirred up something i think someone at
the federal trade commission was
listening that's right the federal trade
commission clearly is a big fan of the
fine print and here's proof here's a
headline the ftc sues turbo tax to stop
misleading ads for free tax prep
software
wow the federal trade commission said
tuesday that intuits ubiquitous
advertising claiming its turbo tax prep
software is free to use is misleading
kind of what george said
and has asked a federal court to order
into it to stop
disseminating the deceptive claim that
consumers can file their taxes for free
using turbo tax according to the
commission the ads
some of which have consisted almost
entirely of the word free
spoke spoken repeatedly mislead people
into believing they can file their taxes
for free with turbo tax in fact most tax
filers can't use the company's free
service because it's not available to
millions of taxpayers
such as those who get a 1099
for work in the gig economy or who earn
farm income the agency said in a press
release the ftc said in 2020
approximately two-thirds of tax filers
could not use turbotax's free product
thus
it's not free though i added that last
part yeah how this is how this works
right yep and uh you know back when we
did this fine print episode this was
back in march 2021 and we sat down me
and you dave and we went through their
investor day report
and it was their entire strategy about
how they're going to turn their billion
dollar company into a bajillion dollar
company by becoming one of the biggest
lenders out there they're trying to sell
you on debt and so they lure you in with
this promise of free
they end up charging you because you
needed one extra form and all of a
sudden you're you know three hours in
and they go well that'll be 60 bucks
that you thought was free and then later
down the road they use all of your data
points to then sell you debt through all
their partners and providers down the
line so all in all not a great company
turns out into its turbo tax is
even when it's free is basically a lead
magnet for
debt products
they're gathering your data to sell you
debt and that's why that's what they're
doing they're using it to collect that
yeah in other words you're being
manipulated in addition to being misled
you are the product that's what it comes
down to
so if you if you needed more ammo here
you can go listen to the whole fine
print episode it's a short one it's
about 20 minutes long or so and we me
and dave we unpacked their their
strategy we talked to some experts we
hear some stories about people who use
turbotax and got screwed and uh the
episode's called how turbo tax is
screwing you so i feel like that's
pretty apt i think you uh i really do
think somebody the ftc was listening to
you i hope they're fans um i mean i
don't want anything with with the you
know the acronym coming after us the irs
the ftc these are scary people i don't
want them on my bad side the dea the dea
why are they all three letters where is
this coming from the fbi the atf we
don't need any of these people
yes
run three letters cia we don't want the
cia no it keeps going
[Laughter]
wow three little three-letter federal
acronyms not good no
and yeah turbo tax has been hammered the
last few years propublica did a huge
piece on them
about misleading this even you know
hassan minaj patriot acted a whole
episode about how turbo tax is hurting
people through this exact thing so i'm
glad someone's finally going after them
more importantly george campbell did it
on the fine print that's right i'm just
saying that's the one america remembers
intuit said in a statement that it will
vigorously challenge the ftc's complaint
claiming arguments are not credible i
think millions of americans would
disagree with that
so i think it's easy to say they're
credible
that's kind of incredible actually yeah
yeah which part of that we we released
ramsey smart tax which we partnered with
tax slayer because we didn't want people
to have to deal with all these hidden
fees right when they're knee-deep in
their taxes and they go oh gosh if
you're a part of ramsey plus it is free
yeah period
end of story you can guarantee we're not
going to try to sell you on debt
this is pretty much sure yeah we're
pretty much sure that's not going to
happen so we're we're not really
gathering data points on you to sell
your dad well not gonna you're not gonna
get the ramsey credit card offer this is
not coming to you sorry yeah so you have
to get your cash back points and airline
miles elsewhere wow
so the federal trade commission has
filed suit on intuit now intuit is not a
little company now they're huge it's a
massive company started with quicken and
then they got mint that was a huge one
yeah they got mint they bought mint and
mint's not doing so well either yeah it
was kind of struggling along well it's a
similar strategy it's just become a debt
company exactly that's how they make
their money now yeah you get free
budgeting yeah but you're gonna get a
lot of opportunity to screw up your
budget like every time you open it that
is ironic they're helping you do a
budget by selling you on lots of debt
yep that works yep yep see this it's all
back to this one home company um i think
they still own rocket mortgage don't
they yeah that sounds right so they're
um i think they're selling you to move
your yeah yeah they're buying up all the
lending companies to have under their
umbrella now
hmm
things that make you say
hmm
federal trade commission said tuesday
that intuits ubiquitous love that
advertising claim
advertising claiming its turbotax prep
software is free to use is misleading
and has asked a federal court to order
into it to stop disseminating
the deceptive claim
that consumers can file their taxes for
free
using turbo tax
now this is actually very interesting
news for some of you that have never
heard anything about this because you've
procrastinated and put off filing your
taxes
and procrastinated and put off filing
your taxes as a matter of fact the irs
is putting out information right now
into the media including us that says
that in the more that more people are
going to file at the last minute this
year than at any time in the history of
the united states
there's going to be a tidal wave of late
and on the bunny on the money at the
last minute filers so if you're one of
those and you're a turbo tax guy uh you
may want to think about changing yeah
jump over to ramsey plus you can join
that and if you're a member of ramsey
plus ramsey smart tax is completely free
if not ramsey smart tax is an online
filing service it's com
very inexpensive and there's not a bunch
of hidden charges and we're not going to
tell you it's free
because it's not unless you're a member
of ramsey plus so there you go and john
deloney did his taxes using smart tax so
if john deloney can do his taxes you can
too
you got this america really we believe i
know i'm impressed too that's pretty
cool
pretty fantastic get your taxes done
guys get it done early you know well
yeah don't procrastinate it's already
it's too late to be early yeah you got
what four hours left you need to get
this done like now
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
so
[Music]
well george i just looked down and saw
we were supposed to talk about ramsey
smart tax we should have woven this uh
mentioned into our little rant that
would have been a little
more precipitous but we'll go ahead and
do it anyway so there we go tax season
is ending uh don't put up with the
garbage of uh the turbo tax people we
just talked to you about that ramsey
smart tax is easy to use you'll get
every federal form you need no hidden
fees right now use the promo code tax 22
and you'll get 25 off filing your
federal return
that means you get our federal classic
software for free and you can get our
premium software with priority support
and a financial coaching session all for
just 20 bucks with the promo code tax
22
and that's for everyone so check it out
guys ready to file your taxes with
confidence go to ramseysolutions.com
smart tax ramsey solutions dot com slash
smart tax tyler is with us in des moines
iowa hi tyler welcome to the ramsey show
thanks dave thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
um okay so i am in baby step two
currently uh i've paid off about 15 000
of my 32 in the last like six months or
so
um and i've got a milestone coming up uh
my girlfriend and i are about to
celebrate our one-year anniversary
and i know you say that i'm not allowed
to step foot in a restaurant unless i'm
working there
but i am working there
and i also get like half off at any of
our like locations
so i want to take her out to a nice
restaurant it is kind of on the on the
higher end
um so i don't know
i guess i'm kind of looking
for permission do you work at this
high-end restaurant or is this a
different one
it's a it's a different location i
thought it would be a little uh
untactful to bring her to where i work
for
an anniversary dinner
so what would this cost you this first
anniversary date
um i'm thinking probably somewhere in
the hundred dollar range
okay um and i i like i set some money
aside i call it my offshore fund uh that
you know just personal money that i get
to use throughout the month um
but uh
so how much blow money do you currently
have in your budget in baby step two
what does your kind of entertainment fun
money look like right now
um i give myself forty dollars a month
um to kind of use whatever um
and
i i i have like 17 bucks in that
envelope left so i'm gonna be dipping
somewhere else um
and i do have a payday in between now
and then so i'd be able to kind of
allocate some different funds here and
there
but i
i know that this relationship is going
to
last the distance so i kind of i don't
want to you know splurge everything all
up front but i also do want to kind of
celebrate those milestones as they come
and this is kind of a big one for us
well what's stopping you from getting a
nice steak and just cooking at home
he was not excited about that option
well yeah but uh well i'm just wondering
you know if you get two nice steaks for
40 bucks and you cook at home you get
some candles you know make it a little
more romantic i think that could be a
great option
that is not a bad option at all we we do
most of our cooking at home as it is so
i guess you know just setting the mood
different kind of change things up i i
see where you're coming from there
i'll let the man who's been married for
a bazillion years speak into this i
think you know it's um would sharon be
upset if you cooked a steak at home dave
sharon would be shocked if i cooked
anything
there's the truth okay so
anyway uh so what do you make
what's your income i make
uh around 40 000 a year and how much
debt have you got
uh i have 18 000 left and um
how old are you
35 okay
all right
the decision itself is not going to
break you one way or the other obviously
okay
when you're 60 you're not gonna go oh
that hundred dollars just screwed up
everything
all right
but what you're wrestling with um you
don't need our permission you're a grown
man
you get to decide what you're going to
do but what you're the the beauty of
what you're dealing with is that you are
at least wrestling with it
and if you will keep that hobby
of wrestling with decisions rather than
just automatically doing them
in your life you'll make much wiser
decisions as you go along
there's a proverb that says he who is
impulsive
exalts folly and you're not being
impulsive
and by the way folly is a verb of a fool
in action
he is impulsive as a fool in action
and you're not impulsive because you're
wrestling with this and you're actually
you know talking it through with us and
you're bouncing it around and so the the
beauty of the conversation is that
you're having the conversation
and so you're going to make good wise
decisions as long as you keep that
habit or that process that
decision-making process front and center
so having done all of that if you decide
to go out to eat we're not going to be
mad at you what we're trying to get you
to do is to constantly be thinking about
and wrestling with every one of these
things and keeping debt
reduction at right in front of your nose
so that you get it done
and so that you can be free so that you
can go out to any time you want so that
you can be wealthy so that you can be
outrageously generous and
so so that 15 years from now you're a
baby steps millionaire and all of that
right
and that's what we're looking at
so uh uh
i'm not going to tell you what to do
and it's not my place to give you a
grown man permission to decide to do
this um but i i'm going to encourage you
and say the fact that you're wrestling
with this is a really good sign for you
and if you just if you wrestle with it
and you decide to do two stakes at home
not a bad decision
if you wrestle with it the fact that
you're wrestled with it is probably
going to make going to the restaurant
okay
but i'm not telling you to do it i'm not
going to tell you not to do it you get
to decide that
it's pretty important george because the
the i'm often asked when i'm doing these
interviews and you are too with the
media what's the biggest mistake people
make with money remember that you know
that interview question and my answer
always is they don't pay attention
and he's paying attention yeah he's
doing the cash envelope system he's
methodical strategic and so if i'm in
his shoes i may go if this isn't going
to slow down my debt snowball maybe i go
make this money extra so that doesn't
affect my plan yeah then i do without
remorse yeah
but but but you know
be concerned
when you step over
a line and that's what he is he's
concerned yeah it's because it's going
it's going to set me i'm you know i
don't want to not do the right thing
and so that's a
the wrestling is where the gold is
that's the wisdom that's where the
wisdom comes from discernment good it's
not the it's not the uh actual answer
that matters as much as the rest it's
not the 50 amount that's the difference
maker here yeah because that's the
difference
at
yeah
sadie is with us sadie's in atlanta
georgia hi sadie welcome to the ramsay
show
hi sir how are you better than i deserve
how can we help right quick
well i graduated college
last year i'm 22 years old we paid or i
paid the whole thing in cash so i
actually have
no credit history whatsoever
but i'd like to move out
hopefully by next year
i'm not sure exactly where i want to
settle so an apartment would be nice to
get but my older brother has been trying
to apply for apartments near my area
here and i'm actually closer to noon in
georgia
and no who bites
he has no credit history either
he's not getting anything does he have
income you know what that's it sadie
that's absolutely not true
your older brother's not telling you the
truth okay because we sat here we had
one of our ramsey personalities sit here
and dial people all over
the united states and dial apartments
and ask them if they needed a credit
score with a good down payment and a
solid or with a reasonable deposit and a
solid job and only about one in five
required a credit score and would not
rent to you and i did this on the fine
print sadie the dirty truth behind your
credit score episode seven go listen to
that with your brother and we'll prove
you wrong he just hasn't tried hard
enough hasn't done his research yeah
he's that's completely false listen to
the fine print episode
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage ronald
and denise are with us hey guys how are
you we're great great honored to have
you where do you guys live richmond
virginia fine welcome to nashville and
all the way here to do a debt-free
stream all the way here to do a debt
free scream on our 20th anniversary no
better place to be free that's awesome i
love it
so how much did you pay off
we paid off about 160 000
in about six years good for you and your
range of income during that time our
range started at about 110 and
after we really got into doing the
program and we picked up part-time jobs
it's now two to 250 depending on the
income from the part-time jobs you're
killing it way to go that's a lot of
money what do y'all do for a living
i'm a school psychologist and i'm
recently retired that's a good thing
congratulations i like this good plan so
what kind of debt was the 160 000
it was credit cards in our house you
paid off your house
looking at weird people
just in time for retirement no debt
anywhere boom
i love it i love it so what started this
journey six years ago you know
you have always said that age doesn't
matter you said race doesn't matter and
you said income doesn't matter and we
are here as witnesses that that is
absolutely true wow we
floundered and squandered so much money
over the years just living and doing
what we thought was okay
but
we went to fpu class at our church six
years ago
and it was the nine week class and when
we heard it it resonated with our spirit
said man this is it this is the right
way to do it it wasn't a get rich quick
scheme but it was the right way
commonsensical
but what happened was
we weren't gazelle intense
we did it we weren't going to give up
all of our credit cards because you got
to have a credit card
and
we had come from previous marriages both
of us okay and so we were older
and
more independent when we got married so
this stuff about joining incomes
no we weren't having not after the last
time not after the last time
and so
we had a my account his account and then
we had a joint account where we would
pay the bills oh we thought we were
doing it we had a percentage based on
what you made and i made and that's the
bill
but you know what we were just slowly
not really getting anywhere we were
treading water
and then two years ago we had our first
grandchild
that made us reevaluate our life and our
legacy
i like these people yeah
already a big fan
big denise fan you're amazing we were
like
dave ramsey told you what to do he told
you three years ago what to do
but we just
kind of did it without the gazelle
intensity and when that baby was born
game on game on
tore up all the credit cards all right
the independence was gone yeah we got
together got our money together felt
like we had gotten a raise
he had a little problem with that
being a man
and i'm going to teach you a
small
version of it
um
being an older
adult
i was 65 years old
got my old school ways it took me a
while to say you know give my check to
someone that i wasn't used to giving it
to use it going from my hand to my
pocket
to the stores
i told myself
ronald you have to leave your ego and
your pride at the front door
wow and let your wife take over this
dave you just don't know how much flock
i got from my male friends
they said i can't believe you giving
your wife your check but i said this was
a way to keep our not only me and my
wife together but also our legacy wow
so now we're working together now we're
working together and game on in the
house game on the houses paid off we got
that's when we picked up the part-time
jobs that ended up being really
lucrative
and we're here to talk to the older
people we see a lot of younger people
here but we're here to say
you can do it age doesn't matter we are
65 and 67. okay the only thing we could
kick ourselves is because we didn't
start sooner but you know when you know
better you do better hey there you go
and we need to thank you publicly we
love you for putting us on this path
you're an incredible story i love you
guys you're amazing powerful man wow
that's powerful preach it about liking
quotes i want to write down right yeah
there's a whole bunch of one-liners
there's it's a whole tweetable event
this is great like like we do anything
on twitter anymore but yeah way to go
you guys you're saying it's never
no okay what's what's the grand baby's
name
rain
r-a-y-n-e brain ivy little girl little
girl oh oh
oh oh and now it begins
so yeah the the the y is a little
different
but that's a big old why right there
that little bitty baby is a big old why
you guys uh that got you going and now
you're 100 free
so uh
ronald uh your old buddies have made fun
of you there uh your house is paid for
yes sir who's laughing now yeah
well i'm coming
they will be laughing after i send this
link to all my friends
[Laughter]
how are you like me now yeah how you
like your man
hey dave i want to also say that
i read your baby steph book and i've
been passing on to a lot of
young people to let them know that you
can do the same thing i did i mean
instead of waiting like i did i got in
my 60s y'all can do it like in your 30s
i passed the book on yet so this
retirement i think it takes more courage
uh and more motivation to to do it the
way you guys did it uh even though you
and i agree it'd be it's all
obviously better at 22 than at 62.
because the math is better but uh but it
it's um
that old dog new tricks thing man
people my age your age we don't like
change
it's harder for us and change requires
more courage that's right transformation
requires more courage and so i'm i think
you're heroes i'm very proud of you
you're amazing people thank you it's so
amazing i just they're they're fun i
know you're the hero you're a rock star
in our world i tell you
you need to get a bigger world
you're bono man
[Laughter]
oh my gosh well we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you that's the
next chapter in your story you will be
millionaires tell people what the secret
to getting out of debt is
it's the mindset once you change your
mind it doesn't matter the income it
doesn't matter any of those other things
we happen to have two incomes but if we
didn't if it was just me we could do the
i could do the same thing it's the
mindset
and working together when you do have
two incomes yeah
big deal that's a big deal okay we we
established that some of your buddies
were picking at you who was your
cheerleaders
my wife mm-hmm okay yeah we didn't tell
a lot of people
no my wife was the main one they kept
selling you know they kept they kept
telling me you're doing the right thing
you're doing the right thing you're
doing the right thing
it turns out
both of you were right and satellite
radio listening to you every day that
was that was my motivation wow
well we're honored you're telling a lot
of people now aren't you you guys are
fun yeah you just lit up a whole
generation i love it that's fun very
well done
all right ronald and denise from
richmond virginia 160 000 paid off house
and everything looking at weird people
did it in six years making 110 to 250
heading into retirement debt free count
it down let's hear a debt free scream
three
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't care who you are that's how it
works right there baby whoa
that's why we do this right here yeah
oh that's fun they're heroes man that's
fun what a neat couple i gotta go back
and watch that and write down all the
quotables
oh man i mean that's a book right there
she's zipping them off there wow no
question but no excuses not too late not
too late there's no you know you can do
it
listen if you thought you if you thought
you couldn't do it i think she just told
you you could i think they just told you
you just got told you just got told
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day john 13 or 16
i have told you these things so that in
me you may have peace
in this world you will have trouble but
take heart i've overcome the world
c.s lewis said hardships often prepare
ordinary people for an extraordinary
destiny
often
often that's very true
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-522
we're going to be doing a segment on how
to do college debt free how to pay for
college debt free college parents and
students will be participating in that
if you're a parent or student you have a
question about going to college debt
free then uh hey we we need to hear from
you we want to put you in that segment
go to ramseysolutions.com
ask put college in the subject line tell
kelly a little bit about what you're
thinking and uh we'll work you into that
show and you can be one of the callers
we never tell you what to say we just
arrange it so that you can actually get
through on these phone lines which is a
bit difficult sometimes
joanne is in raleigh north carolina hi
joanne welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave and george thank you for taking
my call and god bless you both for
everything you do i appreciate it well
thank you you too how can we help
well um
my husband's 75 i'm 65 both retired
uh we sold our house in raleigh last
september
um
when the market was great thought we
would be full-time our fears
um have been touring the country since
then
and have found
that's not the life for us
um so we would like to have a home date
so we've already made a deal um
contracted for a brand new house
near raleigh and
it's about 400 000.
we have 180 in a money market account
and
another well it used to be a hundred in
an investment
um account and that's gone down
to 94 000 which is kind of sickening us
um so we wondered what your advice would
be should we
put all that money towards
the hundred thousand dollar house
i mean it was a paid for house that we
sold what did it sell for we've been
following
325.
okay
and so you and you've still got 280
what's the rv worth
uh about 25. you gonna sell it
no we were gonna take it up to new york
where we have our son and wife and
grandchildren and spend the summers in
it up there
at a campground
okay
all right
um that sounds fun
okay
it is right and how much do you have in
retirement accounts
well
it's i'm retired from new york and north
carolina and then with both of our
social securities we get about
a little over seven thousand dollars a
month yeah but do you have a retirement
nest eggs
no
so you don't have like 401ks or
something like that
no it was all state retirement okay so
you have a good steady income but if you
but this 280 000 between the uh
investment and the cash is all you've
got
yeah
okay
so i thought you said you were going to
pull money out of retirement to pay for
the house how are you doing this no no
the investment account we were wondering
if we should leave that in there no you
should put it all in the house
you should put it in the house you have
a really big monthly income
yeah i know we're black we are very
blessed yeah
and i would use that in you make sure
you keep an emergency fund back and
let's put as much down on the house as
we can and then i want you to work to
get that house paid off as quick as you
can
yeah yes
i don't i don't want you listen i don't
want you married to an 85 year old man
still have a mortgage
i know you know we love you we've been
following you for 10 years you know
actually came and saw you you know in
2013 and
um you know you've changed our life
already but i think you know we feel
like we may have done
something a little stupid here but um
just i just wanted to
hear you call it another option is buy a
280 000 house instead of a 400 000 house
well we've already contracted for this
new house
that's where we started it's looking for
it yeah we tried to find a house for
that and even bid on a couple here in
raleigh and um it is crazy there the
bidding wars they're going for
one house just went for sixty thousand
dollars more than the dancing price yeah
i know
okay well that's the thing i mean
because
i am not i mean we are not thrilled with
the idea of you going into the last
years of your retirement in the next two
decades with house payments so i want
you to clear that house payment on that
400 as quick as you can get that
emergency fund set aside some money for
closing costs the rest is going to be a
big old down payment so you have as
little mortgage as possible so that you
can attack it as quickly as possible
that would be my goal
100 and
340 000 worth of debt and so how quick
do you pay that off with you know 8 000
a month income so yeah you're going to
pay it off but you do need to do it in
like three or four years you don't you
don't need to mess around with this
and uh because you want to get back to
where you were with that paid for
property and then
keep keeping that rv and then moving it
up in there and having your summers
around the grandkids is a cool idea
so but let's let's have a plan to knock
this little mortgage out it's gonna be a
little one and let's get it done and
then start building some investment
dollars beyond that
uh beyond just your monthly income i'd
love for you to have another half
million dollars in a few years and
you've got the ability to do all that
but you're just going to have to
concentrate and focus here so
uh that would be an interesting note
because we have a whole lot of people
that that's their dream
it's an rv it comes up comes up a lot
sell the house i'm an rv
sell the house i'm a rv we get that from
people of all ages and i'm gonna rv
around the country i'm an rv around the
country and um
uh
the moral of the story is it's not for
everyone and this idea that it's always
glamorous uh no it's not no it's not
it's an rv
it's fun and there's an adventure part
to it but it does it can work in and it
obviously did with them and
they're you know they're parking the
thing yeah and uh so and and it's you
know the
the false start of it cost them
something there so
um
if we had their situation to do over
we'd probably say buy a good used rv and
go on the road before you sell your
house
and make sure that your test run make
sure that life is what you want before
you uh on this hot market people are
going should i sell my house and just
live in an rv because i can get so much
for the house right now no you shouldn't
because it might not be what you want to
do
so you ought to go give it a try and
it's why you try a pair of shoes on see
if they fit you know this is a plan
and
check it out open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five daniel
is in kansas city daniel we're a little
short on time go straight to your
question sir
all right so i uh just got married uh
last year uh and we're in baby step two
right now
and there we
are able to we were able to pay off uh
68 000 so far uh we had a total of 130
daniel what's your question before we
run out of time
uh there's two loans that i have uh it's
a heloc and a student loan uh
he lost 18 000 uh the student loans are
52. i'm in the military so i'm going to
be moving soon i just wanted to know
which one we should tackle first what's
your income
um so uh i make about
55 to 60 and then my wife's going to be
starting a job as a nurse she'll be
making about 60 to 65 000 years okay and
that heloc's just going to go in the
debt snowball at that point so list them
all out from smallest to largest student
loans included and just start attacking
the little one with a vengeance with all
you got make minimum payments on the
rest and keep walking that out and that
snowball is going to pick up snow and
we're going to clean up all this debt
real fast getting some extra jobs and if
you sell the house the heloc is going to
clear if you make the move you're
talking about the heloc is going to
clear and and you know you're going to
be you're going to be running through
the student loan and heartbeat then so
but it sounds like you're working on the
student loan first anyway if i heard the
numbers right he said he's got 52 total
in student loans so depends on how
they're all yeah depends on how they're
broken down yeah that would be it so
thank you for your service daniel yeah
we appreciate you man
uh that about puts this particular hour
of the ramsey show in the books uh
george campbell good hour thank you well
done james kelly team in the booth well
done zach all of you good good work good
work good work as always
that does put this hour of the ramsey
show in the books we will be back with
you before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you